mary is with us in medford oregon hi
mary welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so my husband and i recently purchased a
toyota camry 2020.
uh we made a 3 000 deposit
down payment and our monthly payments
are 350. now
we're he wants to get a truck instead
should we trade it in are we going to
lose money on that
can we refinance okay
what's the goal the goal is to pay it
off
but if we can get a lower monthly
payment that would be ideal because
you understand how monthly payments are
lower
no if it's on the same amount of money
borrowed the only way the payment is
lower
is if you extend the time you're in debt
uh so instead of five years it'll be
like six years
if you want a lower payment on the same
amount of debt so what do you owe on
this
um we bought it for 20 grand and so far
we've only been in
it for six months yeah what's your
household income
um 75 okay
you kind of feel like somebody that's
just going to stay in car payments your
whole freaking life to me
okay it just kind of sounds like y'all
aren't that worried about this
um well his car broke down so we just
bought it on the splurge
yeah yeah um yeah i recently
changed jobs and when i changed jobs it
was to a higher income but
that career did not match my
personality and whatnot so now i'm back
at making minimum wage
and so i'm assuming that in within a
year i'll be
back to making 17 an hour
i think the hardest part for me right
now marriage is understanding why
because one thing for me you know and i
can pretty pretty much speak for dave
we're not going to
tell you how to get a lower payment you
know we can walk you through on how to
pay it off
um technically i would say we need to
trade it in as far as and
sell it and and get a cash car um
now your income is doing well making
seventy thousand dollars with a twenty
thousand dollar vehicle is
is not it's not it's not a bad move if
you pay cash for it
but the problem is you're looking for a
lower payment and so
for me i can't teach you how to get a
lower payment yeah and let me
let me walk you through what i heard
okay you said
oh car broke down and so we impulsed a
car
oh now my husband wants to oh he changed
his mind now he wants to impulse a truck
yeah and so the decision-making pattern
you guys have sucks
yeah i mean you're just jumping from one
thing to another like
you know out of the frying pan into the
fire back and forth back and forth back
and forth instead
what i was looking for what i want for
you is a strategy a long-term plan where
you
make moves that get you out of debt and
build wealth and then you can drive
whatever you want to drive
there's nothing wrong with having a nice
car right there's nothing wrong with
that the problem is you guys are just
jumping around all over the place
i mean you jumped into a job out of a
job you jumped into this car and out of
the car
now he wants to jump into a truck and
you know and all you're worried about is
kind of get a lower payment
yeah which is all of this it pretends it
all
indicates that you're going to stay in
debt
because you don't have a passion to get
out a reason to get out and a plan to
get out
here's what i know the average car
payment in america
is a little over 500 a month it's about
514
a month right now over 84 months that's
the average
if you invest 514 dollars in a decent
growth stock mutual fund
in a roth ira from age 30 to age 70
you're gonna have like 5.2 million
dollars in that one account
that's what that stupid car payment's
costing you guys out there
the car payment is the mantra of the
middle class
yeah it's i'm always going to be middle
class if i keep a car payment
it pretty much mathematically ensures
that that's going to be the case now
there's no
shame there's nothing wrong with being
middle class but the point with handling
money
is to move up through that and not speed
making decisions that stick you there
so i hope you like the car it's a 5
million car
that's what we're talking about here and
and you know this idea that i'm going to
get a truck and then i'm going to get
another thing and then the next thing
i'm gonna give me another thing
and that's what most people do by the
way that's normal but most people are
broke
and you called the dave ramsey show
where we specialize anthony and i and
the ramsey personalities
specializing in helping you not be broke
and therefore the first step of that's
get out of debt so
if i'm in your shoes i'm gonna get him a
truck but you know what about a three
thousand dollar one there you go and i'm
gonna sell
this stupid car and get out of debt yeah
so i'm gonna give him his wish
i sure will but yeah we could trade it
in as long as we get a truck that's paid
for
cash yeah you know and you're gonna lose
your butt on this car
yeah but you're out of that you move
yourself out of debt but you've got to
decide what your what your goal is
because you're you're wandering around
all over the place and when you
if you aim at nothing you're going to
hit it every time
and that's what's going on and i'm not
picking on you i'm just observing where
you are i've done the same kind of stuff
i've done it with zeros on the end i've
done all kinds of stupid
butt stuff that's how i know what stupid
looks like yeah and anthony's done
stupid stuff
so we all have done that then but the
thing that clears it up is
the when you put a decision in front of
yourself
you ask yourself does this decision move
me away from my goal or towards my goal
yes
oh wait i don't have a goal so we got to
stop and start we have to
rewind back up let's start there and in
our case we're walking you through the
baby steps which the ultimate goal of
that
is you live like no one else so later
you can live and give like no one else
you drive like no one else so later you
can
drive like no one else you vacate and go
out to eat like no one else
which means not at all until you get
your butt out of debt
then you can vacate and eat like no one
else you know where i eat anywhere i
want to you know where i vacate anywhere
i want to you know what i drive anything
i want to
but i've been doing this stuff 30 years
and i became wealthy because of it yeah
and that enables sharon and i to do
those things but we paid a price to get
there
and you know one of the main reasons
dave you've become you are wealthy and i
am becoming wealthiest because something
that she said that i talk about at
ramsay plus
is how to stop and post purchasing
and one of the main reasons why people
are getting into debt and fall into this
trap is because they're just buying on
impulse
buying on emotions and so you have to do
that with a stick of gum you can't do
that with a freaking car
with a house or something like that so
um i agree with you dave we have to stop
it um
and she has to get on the plane that's a
good point that's a good point
you know i i because i'm a spender by
nature
and so one of the things that that i
share with mary is
that's the type of stuff i did all the
time i just do something i just wanted
to do it i just did it yeah
you know and and it always caught up to
me and kicked me in the back of the head
and then i read that proverb he who is
impulsive
exalts folly that's what the scripture
says
now and i had to think about that a
minute
if you're impulsive you exalt you lift
up
yeah folly now folly if is not a word we
use
right in our day-to-day vernacular in
america today
so i kind of had to think about i looked
it up folly is a fool in action
and so what i what i was when i was
impulsive was i was a fool in action
and i've done some foolish stuff come on
dad when i was impulsive
yes sir he who hastens to be rich will
not go unpunished i've done all kinds of
foolish things
but uh 100 of the time fools are broke
yeah
hurts hurts hurts hurts mary you guys
can do better set yourself a goal and
then decide what the steps are to get
there